welcome to this video playing the
marzipan catch ya please click the sky
reform marzipan catch I don't remember
exactly what it was everyone will one
lost one draw so sounds pretty even ok
let's see what is doing Queen tags a
quick exit I go III this is not the most
ambitious line ever for white but it is
some it is certainly ok black gown does
not have much to fear but the sharp
attempts against the five are also not
that brilliant at least what I know and
I'm currently just experimenting a
little bit with Quincy too I watched a
video serious about it by German Grand
Master yang gustafson on chest to any
form and this is what I know about it
and going Queenie form and I wonder if
there's something wrong already here or
can I wait wait I can just take this
right and g7 hangs what exactly is the
compensation I mean I've lost lots of
time but still it's hard to believe that
this would be worth a pawn now maybe
yeah my quest structure is weak here it
is weak Knight f3 maybe OS is weakening
even more sorry the mutant idea 3 has an
advantage of speeding up my development
quite considerably
but we definitely not help with
realizing the pawn I can go f3 king of
two witnesses the other way to do it now
come on I want to develop quick am it's
not good in terms of structure exact
time is also very important than chess
here checking age seven the seaborne is
we get with scissors kilo with them
maybe black has compensation here it's
very active you know it's in fact quite
likely that he has got compensation
maybe not from the outset but right here
very much possible okay so he lets me
take the H pawn this I'm surprised part
I'm I will take it I mean this is
potentially valuable the outside awesome
checking b7 k so I'm going to take here
I have two parts now
I think this is this might be good yeah
look be to look be one exchanges one
pair of rooks is active route yeah I can
trade this look now this is good look at
you there's a way to hook a two-loop
even would be a check wow that's a long
line okay to look be 18 7 up takes on
age 8 and then he has a check himself on
a one king up rook takes h1 ok it's not
that convincing what what is this idea
actually we should be five maybe
what I want is also i want to protect
the the rook and I want Bishop f3 so
that each was covered and then maybe can
just push the edge porn yeah and rook be
one now is definitely a move would be
one rookie to check in the oneness is
just good for me I think yeah come on
let's try to be channel to be quick here
I thought that this is now a problem for
him I'm threatening Luke takes b5 also a
six rook takes b5 and a bishop move runs
in terms of b8 dropping the h8 rook
black resign yeah just just do the stuff
him just losers huh that was a weird
weird thing here I don't know this i
think that the Queen efore is a normal
thing but think it only has played after
castles this this i have never seen this
kind of sacrifice computer has totally
merciless and wants to play Bishop to h6
yeah it computer does not mind night
before I was really scared about this
but maybe it's not a problem yeah I have
Bishop b5 check in fact also but what is
this here look see one is length okay
yeah I'm willing to believe that this is
good for white but it's not stuff that
you can play that easily okay went here
and and this is this feels a little bit
like compensation in my pawn structure
is weekend I'm slow in development I was
Nadia three years is worsening my
structure I want to speed up here we
don't want to fall so far behind in
development and
he gave up this pawn he I thought b6
would still be very decent even two
pawns down he has pressure against III
against the h-bond and one of my extra
points is just a dollop on this I don't
know about and hear this I don't know h
form f voice is a thing this this is not
really doing that much i was looking at
just line when he gets stuffed back yeah
this is not convincing and i have the
porn he has an apron and I mean okay I'm
probably better somehow but it's this
winning I don't know I don't know and
this is just keeping things together
rupee one is now a threat but this is I
think after look we wanted sits almost
oh we can actually take I didn't see
that I didn't spot this yeah he can do
this using this change now of the
position so we will get 1 pound bag okay
i can try to convert this you hit a long
int game i have one extra porn but I
lost the age porn which is unfortunate
still clearly better for wide but there
are of course joint chances with this
reduced material okay okay thanks for
watching